another thing that dr bright is not  allowed to do at the foundation dr  bright is not permitted to try and solve  every single problem with chainsaws  chainsaws can be quite helpful when it  comes to certain specific tasks they're  great at for instance speedily chopping  up lumber or menacing a group of  unsuspecting teenagers on a road trip  however dr bright would like you to  believe that the application of  chainsaws goes far beyond the realm of  reason or safety chainsaws should not be  used to trim your hair to contain  scp-682  to cut a sandwich or as the ammunition  in a specialized cannon it was fine the  one time at the company christmas party  we all had a good laugh but dr james  will never get his big toe back no  more  saws